احييكم مشاهدينا العربيه ما زالت مستمره
في هذه التغطيه للصراع الجاري في السودان
والذي دخل اسبوعه الثالث فالهدنه الخامسه
لا تزال تتجدد فيما الاشتباكات بين الجيش
بقياده عبد الفتاح البرهان والدعم السريع
بقياده محمد حمدان في عده نقاط من اهمها
محيط القصر الجمهوري في الخرطوم اتهامات
متبادله بين الطرفين بخرق الهدنه على وقع
اشتباكات متقطعه داخل العاصمه وخارجها
الجيش وصل بل طلعاته الجويه بالمروحيات
والطائرات الحربيه على مواقع الدعم السريع
فيما ردت قواته الاخيره بمضادات الطيران
يحدث ذلك في الوقت الذي تتسابق فيه دول
العالم لاجلاء رعاياها
[موسيقى]
وصل عدد الضحايا في معارك الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرد دارفور الى 74 قتيلا على الاقل
خلال يومين وفق نقابه اطباء السودان
النقابه واوضحت الرقم في بيان لها ليومين
الرابع والعشرين والخامس والعشرين من
ابريل ولم يتم حصر العدد بعد لوفيات يومي
الاربعاء والخميس في خضم استمرار المعارك
العنيفه في الجنينه
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك معنا كيف هي الاوضاع الان وهل ما
زالت الاشتباكات مقتصره على الجنينه ام
توسعت
نعم حتى الاشتباكات في الجنينه الان توقفت
بفضل الهدنه التي وقعت او يتفق عليها
طرفي القتال المجموعات السكانيه المتقاتله
في الجنينه منذ خمسه ايام الوضع الان يتجه
نحو التهدئه في غرب دارفور وليس في شركه
دارفور يعني كتب قبل قليل دارفور الوضع
اتجه نحو التهدئه تماما
وهنالك جهود كبيره تقودها الادارات
الاهليه وايضا بعض
يعني اعيان المجتمع المدني في غربه دارفور
بهدف اعاده الامور الى طبيعتها
يعني القوات التي تحدث عنها حاكم اقليم
دارفور حتى الان لم تصل الى مدينه الجنينه
ولكنه تحدث وقال بان هذه القوات متحركه
نحو الجنينه بهدف الدخول بين
المتخاصمين هنالك يعني لا نقول استباب
للامن هنالك انفلاتات وقعت صباح اليوم
وهنالك ايضا اطلاق للعيره الناريه ولكن كل
هذه الاشياء هي مقارنه مع الايام الماضيه
عاديه جدا ويمكن السيطره عليه هنالك
احاديث تشير الى نزوح اكثر من مليون شخص
الى المدارس والمساجد والى الاحياء الامنه
داخل
الجنينه مركز
كان بها رقم كبير جدا من النازحين جميع من
كانوا في مراكز الايواء نجحوا الى الاحياء
الامنه داخل مدينه الجنينه ويحتموا
بالمدارس ويحتموا
بالمساجد ما زالت
المجموعات المتفلجه التي هاجمت يعني سوق
الجنينه وهاجمت المؤسسات في الجنينه تحوم
حول المدينه ويمكن ان تاتي مره اخرى ايضا
وتعبت
هذه الجماعات هل معروف انتمائها لمين هل
معروف من اين تاتي بهذه الاسلحه ام لا
العمل السلاح في دارفور في فتره سابغه
يعني تمت عمليه جمع للسلاح ولكن هذا الجمع
لم يكن جمع كلي في الاربع سنوات الماضيه
هنالك سلاح كثير جدا ينتشر في ايدي
المواطنين هنالك ايضا مجموعه من عربات ذات
الدفع الرباعي موجوده بايدي المواطنين كل
هذا اساهم مساهمه كبيره في هذه
الازمه اضافه الى مخزن الشرطه الذي تم
نهبه بجسم شرطه الجنينه
وتم نهب 6000 قطعه سلاح اسلحه ثقيله
وخفيفه
اكثر انه كيف يمكن نهب مخازن الشرطه هل
الشرطه مثلا
تركت هذه الاماكن ام كيف
استطاعوا ان يحصلوا عليها من مراكز الشرطه
والمخازن الشرطه
هي الاحداث عندما بدات بدات بين الدعم
السريع والجيش في موقع محدد
بالجنينه ولكن انتقلت فجاه الى اماكن اخرى
وانتقلت الى نهب وسلب شرطه لا تستطيع
مقاومه الاعداد الكبيره التي هجمت على
المركز واخذت اخذت الاسلحه وايضا اخذت حتى
السيارات هنالك ثمانيه سيارات للشرطه ايضا
تم نهبها من جسم الشرطه بالاضافه الى هذه
الاسلحه الشرطه لا تستطيع ان تقاوم
الاعداد الكبيره من الاطفال والنساء وايضا
عدد من المتفلتين الذين هجموا عليها من كل
الاتجاهات طب بالنسبه للمستشفيات كان
الوضع سيء جدا في الايام الماضيه وكان
هناك ايضا عمليات سلب ونهب للمستشفيات
ماذا في تفاصيل اليوم كيف هو الوضع في
المستشفيات لانه يقال بانه مستشفيات
الجنينه هي خارج الخدمه
نعم موصفات ما زالت خارج الخدمه ولكن
هنالك مستشفيات ميدانيه هنالك يعني بعض
المراكز
لكل طرف مراكز صغيره جدا يتم علاج الجرحى
فيها يتم عمل
الاثراءات الاوليه للاسعافات الاوليه في
هذه المراكز ولكن قطعا لا يوجد تدخل جراحي
ولا يوجد ايضا جهاز للاشياء بعد ان تم
تدمير جهاز الاشعه الموجود الوحيد في
الولايه الوضع الصحي ما ذلك كما هو لا
يوجد تحسين في الوضع الصحي مناشرات كثيره
بالتدخل لتحسين الوضع الصحي وتحسين الوضع
الانساني اليوم الهلال الاحمر نزل الى
الارض بهدف يعني اجزاء الجرحى وبهدف ايضا
اخذ الجثث الموجوده في احياء المدينه
والان ما زالت اللجان المحايده التي دخلت
بين الطرفين تعمل منذ الصباح بهدف الى
الجرحى وبهدف تحسين الوضع الانساني والصحي
بمدينه جنينه وما زلت الامور في الوضع
الصحي لم تعد لان الذمار كبير وحجم الدمار
كبير في المنشات الصحيه هنالك سرقه تامه
لصيدليات والمخازن الادويه طيب صالح
بالنسبه للمنظمات الدوليه هل هي متواجده
هل تتمكن من القيام بعملها في ظل هذه
الاشتباكات وهذه الاوضاع المتوتره
تم اجلاء جميع العاملين بالامم المتحده او
تمت دمار تام
لمقرات هذه المنظمات
منظمه الغذاء العالمي منظمه الهيل الدوليه
عدد كبير جدا من المنظمات العامله
بالجنينه تم تدمير مقراتها تماما لا
تستطيع ان تعود في مثل هذه الظروف وفي مثل
هذه
الاوضاع ولا يوجد ابدا في الجنينه يعني
عامل في الامم المتحده يقوم الان بهذه
المهام
الا الا وان تباشر مهام من مكان اخر او
عبر الشركاء وطنيين موجودين داخل الجنينه
لكن في الجنينه الان لا يوجد اي وجود
لمنظمه عالميه شكرا لك الصحفي صالح ابو
علامه كنت معي من اقليم دارفور
وفي عموم السودان قالت اللجنه التمهيديه
لنقابه اطباء السودان ان عدد المدنيين
الذين قتلوا منذ بدء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع ارتفع الى 387 قتيلا
وذكرت اللجنه في بيان ان الاشتباكات اسفرت
عن اصابه
1928 مدنيا حتى الان واشار البيان الى
سقوط عشره من القتلى المدنيين امس الخميس
بينما اصيب 80 اخرون بينهم حالات غير
مستقره
الجيش السوداني كان اعلن هدنه جديده
استجابه لمساعي سعوديه وامريكيه واعرب
الجيش السوداني عن امله في التزام من
وصفهم بالمتمردين في اشاره لقوات الدعم
السريع بمتطلبات سريان الهدنه واوضح الجيش
السوداني ان تمديد الهدنه تم استجابه
لمساعم سعوديه امريكيه لتهيئه الظروف
لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف الجنسيات
بدورهم رحب اعضاء الاليه الثلاثيه التي
تضم الاتحاد الافريقي والتهيئه الحكوميه
والدوليه والامم المتحده بتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار كما رحبت به المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات وبريطانيا وامريكا
ودعوا الى التنفيذه بالكامل كما رحبت
الاطراف باستعداد طرفي النزاع في السودان
للدخول في حوار من اجل تحقيق وقف دائم
للاعمال العدائيه وضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه دون عوائق
هذا واصدرت قياده الدعم السريع السوداني
بيانا تضمن شكرا وتقديرا للاليات الثلاثيه
واللجنه الرباعيه وشكلت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده على جهودهما
المستمره في اجلاء المواطنين والمقيمين
منذ اندلاع الازمه في السودان واعلن بيان
الدعم السريع التزامها بمقترح ثلاثيه
والرباعيه بتمديد الهدنه الانسانيه لمده
72 ساعه بدا من الثانيه عشر من مساء
الخميس السابع والعشرين من ابريل الجاريه
من جانبها رحبت القوى المدنيه الموقعه على
الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان بالمبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه لتمديد الهدنه لمده 72
ساعه وشددت على ضروره الالتزام بها من اجل
الوصول لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار واضافت
انها تتابع عن كتب خطوات تنفيذ المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه الراميه لوقف
المواجهات في السودان وتشد على ايدي قياده
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع التي تعاطت
بايجابيه مع هذه المبادره
من الخرطوم ينضم الي مصباح احمد رئيس
دائره الاعلام في حزب الامه القوميه
والقياده في الحريه والتغيير اهلا بكم
معنا استاذ مصباح هذه الهدنه الخامسه هل
نعول ان يكون فيها التزام اكثر من الهدى
الاربعه الماضيه التي تخللتها اشتباكات
ولم يكن هناك التزام تام فيها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا جزيلا لك
وتحيه لك
لقناه العربيه والمشاهدين
فعلا الهدنه الخامسه التي تجري اليوم في
يومها الاول بدات اليوم الاول منذ الصباح
[موسيقى]
يعني اشتباكات في بعض المناطق في ولايه
الخرطوم خاصه سيندرمان وفي جبل اولياء وفي
منطقه محيط القياده العامه شرقا اتجاه بري
وامتداد مصر هنالك اصوات للرصاص يعني تسمع
وكذلك ايضا تعليق للطائرات الحربيه
واعتقد ان ولكن فيما يلي اليوم او كل
الساعات الماضيه كان هنالك يعني هدوء هدوء
حرير في بعض الاتجاهات اعتقد ان هذه الغده
معوله عليها كثيرا في انها اذا ثبتت واذا
التزمت طرفان بها بصوره المنظومه ستكون هي
اساس يمكن
ان يبنى عليهم تطويرها الى وقف اطلاق
النار وهو الاساس الذي بنيت عليه المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه
وبالتالي نحن بالنسبه لنا نراقب هذا الوضع
بحذر
الاطراف
الان على المراقبه استاذ مصباح ام هناك
ايضا مبادرات من قبل
والاحزاب السياسيه والمدنيين في الخرطوم
لدفع
الجهات المتصارعه والمتحاربه الى
الاستفاده من هذه الهدنه والوصول الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار
هذه المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه تم
تصميمها بتنسيق تامه بيننا وبين الاطراف
التي قدمتها
لانه نحن نعتقد ان الظروف الحاليه
والتعقيلات في المشهد السياسي تتطلب ان
تكون هنالك اطراف دوليه تكون هي رقيبه
وتكون كذلك ايضا تدفع باتجاه ضروره تثبيت
الهدئه والهدنه وكذلك وقف اطلاق النار
ولذلك نحن نعمل مع كل هذه الاطراف بتنسيق
تام الاليه الثلاثيه والرباعيه الدوليه
وكذلك الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
والتواصل مع الطرفين
باعتبارنا نحن ايضا على الارض القوه
المدنيه كلها هي منوط بها ان تدفع
القياده استاذ مسموح يعني سيد حميدتي
والسيد البرهان ام تتواصلون مع الضباط او
لجان مثلا من قبل الطرفين
نعم هنالك تواصل مع الطرفين هناك تواصل
صحيح ان هناك صعوبه في اللقاءات او في
التواصل المباشره ولكن هنالك اتصالات تتم
ما بين القوى المدنيه خاصه القوه الموقع
على اتفاق الايطالي والقياده الدعم السريع
وقياده الجيش
وهنالك يعني تبادل الوجهات النظر وايضا
استجابه حقيقه من الطرفين لهذه الهدنه
بصوره نعتقد انها ايجابيه يمكن ان نبني
عليها ولذلك نحن نعتقد انه الخطوات التي
مضت في الايام الماضيه والتي ستمضي في
الايام المقبله ستكون هي
التي تختبر اراده الطرفين لجنوحي الى
الحوار وقت
الخطوات التاليه بعد هذه الهدنه وبحال تم
الالتزام بها بشكل تام
المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه مبنيه على
تثبيت الهدنه ثم تطويرها لوقف اطلاق النار
ثم لقاءات غير مباشره او لقاءات
من طرفين من الطرفين بممثلين من الطرفين
لمناقشه
وقف اطلاق النار والبدء في حوار جاد
لانهاء هذه الازمه وانهاء الحرب بصوره
كامله طب هل بان من الممكن ان يكون هناك
تفاوض لانه حتى الان لغه او لهجه التصعيد
ما زالت مستمره بانه لا حوار من دون
استسلام هذا الطرف او الطرف الاخر هل
لمستم اي نيه جديه
بترحيب باي حوار من الممكن ان يحصل او اي
مفاوضات من الممكن ان تحصل
[موسيقى]
يعني هذه الحرب بهذه الطريقه ليس هنالك اي
وسيله اخرى ولا ولا هنالك اي نتيجه ممكنه
تتحقق من هذه الحرب غير مزيد من من
المعاناه بالشعب السوداني الان في تقديرنا
ان هنالك ادراك من الطرفين لان هذه الحرب
الروسيه وغير مؤديه ولا بد من ان تقف بشكل
ما ولكن حتى الان لم تتبلور الرؤيه عن
كيفيه وقف هذه الحرب شكرا لك مصباح احمد
رئيس دائره الاعلام في حزب الامه القوميه
والقياده في الحريه والتغيير
اكد السفير الروسي لدى السودان اندريه ان
الوضع الامني في السودان ما يزال متوترا
مضيفا ان الاشتباكات المتفرقه مستمره بين
الحين والاخر بالاضافه الى ان الطيران
يعمل من وقت لاخر وفق قوله وذكر تشيرنافول
ان بلاده تعمل على اجلاء المواطنين الروس
من السودان وان العمل قائم على اختيار
افضل طرق الاجلاء
تفاعلها مع الوضع الانساني القائم في
السودان شكلت الحكومه الاثيوبيه لجنه
وطنيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الصراع
الدائر في السودان وادعت الحكومه
الاثيوبيه اطرف الصراع السوداني الى وقف
الاقتتال وانهاء معاناه المدنيين واكدت
دعمها للحلول السودانيه من دون تدخل اطراف
خارجيه الزياده نتابع بقلق بالغ تطورات ما
يجري في السودان وقد قمنا بتشكيل لجنه
وطنيه تتراسها الخارجيه الاثيوبيه
بالتعاون مع جهات رسميه اخرى وقد قمنا
بارسال فريق الى الحدود مع السودان للقيام
بتسهيل عبور النازحين من الحرب الدائره
هناك ونامل ان يحل السلام في السودان في
اقرب وقت ممكن
الصراع الدائر في السودان له تاثيرات
سلبيه على المفاوضات الثلاثيه في قضيه سد
النهضه ولا يمكن استئناف المفاوضات ما لم
يحل السلام في السودان ويكون هناك تركيز
تام من الجانب السوداني هذا الوضع يجعلنا
ننتظر حلول السلام في السودان
في الاثناء قالت تجمع الصيادي للمهديين
السودانيين في بيان ان عددا من الصيدليات
والمصانع والشركات ومخازن الادويه تعرضت
لعمليات نهب وسلب في عده مناطق واضاف بان
الوضع الصحي ازداد هشاشه مع احتلال بعض
المستشفيات من قبل القوات كما نوه البيان
الى ان انعدام الامداد الدوائي والطبي عن
المراكز الصحيه ينذر بكارثه صحيه للشعب
السوداني
اكد الهلال الاحمر السوداني للعربيه ان
الجثث في الخرطوم كثيره ولا يمكن تغطيتها
مؤكدا ايضا ان هناك حاجه الى ضمانات امنيه
للعمل على الارض
لا اول حاجه طبعا في الخرطوم الجثث عدد
كبير جدا واحد اثنين اتساع الجغرافيه
بتاعه ولايه الخرطوم يعني نحن لو عايزين
نغطي ولايه الخرطوم كلها بمحليات السبعه
هي هي حاجه ضخمه جدا عدد سكانها اصلا في
الامتدادات الحضريه
ولايه الخرطوم فيها ما يقارب 10 مليون
نسمه العشره مليون نسمه للمواطنين طبعا
يشكل تقريبا اقل شويه من ربع سكان السودان
فالعمل في عمل صعب جدا يحتاج لضمانات
امنيه حتى الاطراف المتنازعه تضمن انه تصل
المعلومه لاصغر جندي في اي منطقه معينه
تحديات بتواجه نفسك تتمثل في حاجتين اول
حاجه في عدم وجود ضمانات امنيه كافيه على
مستوى ولايه السرطوم رغم انه الطرفين
بيعلنوا عن هدنه وقف اطلاق نار لكن نحن
بنحتاج بمانات امنيه لانه بالنسبه لنا
المتطوعين الدهون باخلاء هذه الجثث او
باعمالهم اهم عنصر للهلال الاحمر خالص
يعني اهم من الموظفين المطوعين
حصلت قناه العربيه على صور حصريه لعمليات
الاجلاء الجوي للرعايه الاجانب من السودان
والتي تجري تحت اشراف الجيش السوداني حيث
تظهر الصور اصطفاف طائرات عسكريه لاجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب وحتى السودانيين
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اظهرت صور تم التقاطها بالطائره من
دون طيار استمرار عمليات الاجلاء
للمواطنين ودبلوماسيين في الميناء البحري
الرئيسي في شرق السودان
[موسيقى]
العربيه تبعت كذلك اللحظات الاولى لوصول
سفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده في السعوديه
نتابع الان نشاهد بدا عمليات تجهيز السلم
لبدء انزال الرعايه
القادمين من ميناء بورت سودان وعددهم 52
شخص من من 12 جنسيه نتحدث على دبلوماسيين
وعائلات واطفال وحتى كذلك كبار سن لانه
شاهد القوات العسكريه متواجده لاستقبال
الرعايه هنا في هذا في رصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بعد رحله استمرت عشره ساعات
كنا على متن هذه السفينه نرافقها من قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده الى ميناء بورد
السودان واستمرت عمليات الاجلاء في ظرف
ساعه واحده فقط عبر الزوارق سريعه قامت
بنقل الرعايه من ميناء بورسودان الى
ظهر هذه السفينه السفينه جلاله الملك
الجبيل التابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
ومن ثم انطلقت مباشره من المياه الاقليميه
السودانيه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده في رحله استغرقت كذلك عشره ساعات
فيما يتعلق بالتجهيزات الخاصه بالرعايه
هنا قامت القوات البحريه السعوديه بتجهيز
غرف نومتكانات لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك توفير
كافه المواد التموينيه والاعاشيه وكذلك تم
الكشف والتاكد من صحه وسلامه كافه الرعايه
من خلال وجود عياده طبيه هي مجهزه للتعامل
مع الحوادث والاصابات وكذلك اجراء
العمليات الخفيفه من خلال اطباء عسكريين
سعوديين متواجدون في هذه العياده للتعامل
مع اي حاله كذلك تم فتح كافه المواقع
المخصصه للاعاشه لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى
يستطيعوا التزود من الطعام والمشروبات
شابه ذلك طوال مده الرحله كذلك التعامل
بشكل انساني كبير جدا وواضح خلال طوال هذه
الرحله من خلال التعامل مع الرعايه وعند
اقترابنا من قاعده الملك الفيصل البح
ودخلنا المياه الاقليميه السعوديه التقينا
بعدد كبير من الرعايه نتحدث على يعني
شرحوا وعبر لنا عن امتنانهم وتقديرهم
الحكومه السعوديه قامت باجلائهم من ميناء
بورت سودان بعد ان كانوا في الخرطوم
وقاموا بالسفر برا الى ميناء بورسودان في
مده او في مسافه تصل 850 كيلو متر يعني
وثقوا هذه اللحظات عند اقترابهم من قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده وثقوا عبرها
هواتفهم هذه اللقطات واختلفت المشاعر بعد
ان كان هنالك مشاعر خوف وعدم استقرار
اختلفت كليا بعد وصولهم الى بر الامان هنا
على ارض على ارض السعوديه وتحديدا فعلى
رصيف قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
[موسيقى]
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان في تصريحات
خاصه للعربيه ان بلاده مستمره في جهودها
لاقناع طرفي الصراع بوقف القتال والتفاوض
مضيفا ان جنوب السودان لم تحصل على موافقه
رسميه من البرهان بشان مبادره ايجاد وان
حكومته تجد صعوبه في الوصول الى قائد
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو هاتفيا منذ
سته ايام
من سيد برهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي الاتصال
يمكن انتاج القائد جاي
وتغير في المحال وتمشي للمهال معين
في وقت
ما كان سايل انه الناس يكونوا يتصلوا في
اي وقت
رسلنا الجواب المقترده رسلنا له رسلنا
لبرهان ورسلوه كمان
الرئيس الفقير نيابه عن الدول
ذكرت طبيبه سودانيه ان اسعار تذاكر
الباصات في السودان اصبحت باهظه ولا يمكن
لكثير من المواطنين تحملها كما ان الوصول
الى محطات البساط اصبح خطرا بسبب اطلاق
النار بين الطرفين
التي تمكننا من التنقل من مكان الى اخر
واضيف على ذلك الشوارع التي لا نعلم مدى
خطورتها لانها فقط تبدو امنه وربما يبدا
اطلاق النار بين الطرفين في اي وقت لذلك
رحله الوصول الى محطه الباص كانت صعبه بحد
ذاتها لكننا وصلنا اليها واكتشفنا ان
اسعار التذاكر ارتفعت بشكل كبير لتصبح
اكثر من 70 دولار بعدما كانت اقل من 10
دولارات حيث ان الكثير من السودانيين لا
يمكنهم تحمل تكلفتها وهم الان عالقون في
الخرطوم بسبب ارتفاع اسعارها
قطعت دوريه تتبع لقوات الدعم السريه مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اثناء مدا خله مباشر
على الهواء من شارع الستين في العاصمه
الخرطوم حيث جرى حوار بينهما قبل ان
يتركوه ليستكمل عمله نتابع يذهب الطلاب
الى المدارس هل يذهبون الى مؤسساتهم جدا
جدا
اذا مشاهدينا نتابع الان دوريه
لربما احد المكونين تطالب مراسل العربيه
من الخرطوم سالم الهاشمي باطفاء الكاميرا
اذا
كنا عارفين الله
الشباب
[موسيقى]
لا ادري احدى الدوريات الان يتحدثون مع
مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي لا ندري لاي
جهه تتبع هذه الدوريه الان تغادر
سالم انت معي تسمعني بس شغالين يعني
شغالين بس بننقل ما عندنا حاجه والله
ان شاء الله
سالم تسمعني
اذا مشاهدي اسمعك نتابع معكم هذه الدوريه
التي
استوقفت
العربيه
وسالته عما يقوم به وقال بانه يقوم بالضغط
الاحداث
مالوفه
سالم ماذا يدور
في الشارع ده ممكن يكون فيه نعم
نعم اسمعك الان انا بخير الحمد لله وهي
قوه تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع جاءت في هذه
المنطقه وهم الان يطلبونني للحديث نعم
اذا مشاهدينا الان نتابع
ربما الي من قوات الدعم السريع تتحدث مع
العربيه سالم الهاشمي وربما تستفسر منه عن
طبيعه ما يقوم به وربما الجهه التي يتحدث
معها سالم ماذا دار بينكم
نعم هم يستوثقون عن نقل الاحداث وقالوا
انهم يبحثون يجب ان ننقل ما هو على الارض
وان لا نزور الحقائق هذه هي العبارات التي
ذكرتها هذه القوه الان كانت قوه من
سيارتين تتبع للدعم السريع بالفعل لكن لم
يتعرضوا لنا نحن الحمد لله بخير وحتى
الفريق الموجود معي الحمد لله كلهم بخير
الان القوه تحركت مباشره وقدموا اعتذارا
لنا عن هذه المقاطعه
خطر جديد يزيد تعقيد الوضع في السودان
منظمه الصحه العالميه حذرت من خطر انتشار
فيروسات قاتله من مختبر صحي قريب من مناطق
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
المعمل القومي للصحه العامه في الخرطوم
الذي يقع على بعد امتار من القياده العامه
للجيش التي تشهد اشتباكات مسلحه متكرره
خلال الايام الاخيره المعمل اصبح مصدر قلق
على المستوى الدولي حيث اعلنت منظمه الصحه
العالميه على لسان المدير التنفيذي لاداره
الطوارئ بها الدكتور مايكل رايند ان الفرق
الميدانيه تقيم الوضع
الخطوره تكمن في احتواء المعمل على عينات
من فيروسات وبكتيريا خطيره كالحصبه
والكوليرا والتي اذا منتشرت في الظروف
الصحيه الحاليه
ستتسبب في كارثه لن يستطيع اي من الاطراف
المتصارعه علاجها
شحف المستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
والعاملين في القطاع الصحي
العربيه
اعلنا رئيس الوزراء باحمد اجراء مباحثات
هاتفيه مع قائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان بشان ضروره تسويه الخلافات بين
الجانبين واكد باحمد عبر حسابه على تويتر
مع البرهان ضروره تحقيق الاستقرار في
السودان وتسويه الخلافات بعد الاشتباكات
التي اندلعت بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
كما قالت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بانها تقدر
الظروف التي يمر بها السودان وتبذل قصار
جهدها لدعم جهود وقف الصراع كما اشارت
الخارجيه الاثيوبيه الى تشكيل لجنه وطنيه
اثيوبيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الصراع
في السودان واضافت بانها تامل في ان يتوصل
اطراف الصراع في السودان لاتفاق من دون
تدخل اطراف خارجيه
يعتبر السودان من اكثر الدول الافريقيه
التي لها حدود مشتركه مع الدول الجاره
نتعرف الى الدول المحاديه للسودان
والممرات البريه والبحريه
جمهوريه السودان محاطه بعده دول من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تحدها سبعه دول شمالا وغربا
وجنوبا مع تعدد المعابر البريه والممرات
المائيه لها الجاره الشماليه مصر تتشارك
مع السودان بحدود طولها
1276 كيلومترا في منطقه صحراويه بشكل عام
وبها معبران رئيسيه هما اشكيت وارجين
ليبيا على الجهه الاخرى تربطها بالسودان
حدود تمتد ل 300 و82 كيلومترا في بيئه
تتنوع تضاريسها ما بين صحراء وجبال وسهول
يوجد معبر واحد بين الدولتين هو العوينات
قرب المثلث الحدودي بين الدولتين ومصر
الى الغرب من السودان شريط حدودي مع تشاد
طوله
1403 كيلومترات ومعبر رئيسي يربط بين
مدينتي الجنينه في دارفور وادري في تشاد
اكثر حدود للسودان تربطها بجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى وتقل عن 200 كيلومتر مع
معبر وحيد هو امدافوج بالقرب من هذه
الحدود نجد اطول حدود للسودان وهي مع دوله
جنوب السودان طولها 1900 كيلو متر وبها
عشره معابر حدوديه متفق عليها بين
الدولتين الا انه لم يتم افتتاح كل هذه
المعابر في جنوب شرق البلاد تشترك السودان
مع اثيوبيا بسبعمائه واربعه واربعين مترا
من الحدود مع معبر رئيسي هو الفشقه سابع
الدول المحاذيه للسودان اريتريا مع حدود
طولها 605 كم ومعبر وحيد هو طوكر
وفي الجهه الشرقيه من السودان وممراتها
البحريه على البحر الاحمر فهي تضم مينا
اين رئيسيين هما ميناء بورتسودان وسواكن
حسن غوليد العربيه
رصدت كاميرا العربيه وضع عمليات الاجلاء
في مدينه بورتسودان واضاف مراسل العربيه
في المدينه ان الهيئات المعنيه تعمل بشكل
مستمر لاستقبال رعايه الدول بهدف اجلائها
الى بلدانها
هذا هو احد المراكز الايوائيه المؤقته
التي تعمل على حصر وتسجيل اسماء الراغبين
في الخروج
اعداد كثيره وصلت خلال هذا الاسبوع
والاعداد في استمرار في ازدياد خلال
الساعات الماضيه الباصات السفريه احمد
تاتي من العاصمه الخرطوم من مدينه عطبره
من مدينه مدني بوسط السودان هذه الاعداد
تصل تباعا الى مدينه بورسودان
للتنسيق وللترتيب لعمليه الاجلاء وعمليه
المغادره من شرق السودان هنا احمد هيئه
الموانئ البحريه تجتهد عبر اللجام مختلفه
وعبر تنسيق مشترك مع الجيش ومع القوات
النظاميه لتهيئه الاوضاع والظروف هي تعمل
الان على مدى 24 ساعه
استضافت مئات من رعايه الدول داخل احد
دورها ومقرها في تنسيق وفي اشراف تؤكد
عليه الهيئه بانها ستمضي لتوفير كل ما
يلزم لانجاح هذه العمليه الى جانب التنسيق
مع جهات اخرى
من ام درمان ينضم الينا الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا كيف يمكن ان تصف
لنا الوضع في ام درمان التي تتركز فيها
حقيقه الاشتباكات في الايام الاخيره هل
هناك التزام بهذه الهدنه اليوم ام لا
يعني
طائرات الحربيه تشل
دعوه والتلفزيون حيث تتمركز وتتحصل عدد من
قوات الدعم السريعه في هذه المنطقه هذه في
هذه اللحظات يعني
المضادات الارضيه التي تتصدى لطلاعات
الجويه ولكنها لم تصلح اصابه هذه الطائرات
الان هذا الوضع في مدينه بدا منذ نصف ساعه
هذه الغارات الجويه والرد من المتصفات
الارضيه
يعني الوضع يبدو كان فيه هدوءا حذرا في
هذه المنطقه خاصه بانها ربما هي مع مناطق
اخرى هي التي تسيطر عليها الدعم السريع او
انتشرت فيها من خلال هذه الحرب على مستوى
ولايه الخرطوم كانت هنالك عده اشتباكات
جرت موندو فجره اليوم وحتى
المساء يعني شاهدنا ذلك وتابعناه من خلال
عدد من المصادر التي تحدثت الينا في مدينه
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه في مدينه الخرطوم في
الجانب الجنوبي منها ايضا في منطقه جبل
اولياء وهنالك كانت اشتباكات عسكريه ما
بين الجانبين الجديد في هذه اللحظه يعني
عدد من المصادر تحدثت ايضا في مدينه بحري
على ان المنطقه الصناعيه في مدينه بحري
تتعرض لعمليات سلوانات وهذا كان واضحا من
خلال الايام الفائته ولكنها ربما عادت هذه
عمليات السلب والنهب من
عدد التي تتواجد في هذه
المنطقه منذ عده ايام وهنالك عدد من
الحرائق لعدد المحال والمصانع التجاريه
الموجوده او الغذائيه الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه على مستوى مدينه ام درمان هنالك
كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل صوت الطائرات
الحربيه في سماء المدينه ينتشر بكثافه وفي
هذه اللحظات ايضا استمع اليها الان
بالنسبه لهناك ايضا في وسط من الخرطوم
جزيره توتي كنا قرانا اليوم بان ايضا
تتعرض للقصف هل لديك اي معلومات حولها
وماذا تعني هذه المنطقه من يتواجد فيها
اكثر من يسيطر عليها
هذه الجزيره من موقع الاستراتيجي
والتاريخي هي تقع ما بين منطقه من الازرق
والنيل الابيض وفي منطقه المجرى المجرى
منطقه او جزيره تتواجد بها عدد من
المحاصيل البستانيه تزرع داخل هذه المنطقه
تتواجد فيها عدد من التجمعات السكانيه منذ
فتره قديمه جدا
تربط هذه الجزيره مع مدينه الخرطوم يربطها
جسر معروف في هذه المنطقه وتنتشر فيها
زراعه المحاصيل البستانيه وعدد من
الخضروات التي تعتمد عليها المدينه مدينه
الخرطوم بشكل واضح هو مباشر ربما لا تعاني
هذه المنطقه او لا تنتشر فيها كثافه
سكانيه كبيره لا تعاني من الضيقه السكانيه
بغدر ما فيها من اهميه ولكن هذه المنطقه
هي محاذيه منطقه القصر الجمهوري ومنطقه
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم ربما عدد من الشظايا
او عدد من القذائف اثناء الاشتباك
المتبادل سقطت في هذه المنطقه ولكن هذه
المنطقه لم تكن محل صراعه لم يحاول اي طرف
من الاطراف السيطره عليها ولكن من الج
انب الذين
بحثوا تتواجد قوات الدعم السريع في تلك
المنطقه والمعروفه بقصر الشباب والاطفال
في هذه تلك المنطقه ربما عدد من القذائف
تكون موجهه الى هذه المنطقه باعتبار ان
العين من تلك المنطقه واضحه واكثر
وضوحا فيمكن ان تكون من تلك المنطقه هذه
اردت ان تصف لنا المشهد يعني الطرقات
اليوم هل هناك من حركه هل الناس تستطيع
التنقل الى حد ما من اجل شراء حاجياتهم من
اجل ايضا النزوح الى مناطق اكثر امنا هل
تلحظون هذه الحركه ام ما زلت الطرقات
فارغه ويعني ليس هناك من شجاعه لاحد ان
يتنقل في هذه المناطق خاصه التي يتركز
فيها القصف او الاشتباكات
يعني نحن دخلنا في في ايام
هذه الحرب على مستوى مدينه ام درمان يبدو
الوضع امنا وطبيعيا عاده الحياه طبيعيه
هذا ذكرناه تكرارا مرارا وذكرنا من خلال
العديد من الشواهد على ذلك في مدينه
باستثناء مناطق ليست كبيره تسيطر عليها
قوه يعني فتحت المحل التجاريه مثلا هل
المدارس مثلا تفتح ابوابها ام يعني كيف
يمكن ان تصف لنا الحياه لان هل هي عادت
الى طبيعتها بشكل تام ما قبل الصراع
نعم رغم الضائقه المعيشيه ولكن عاده
المواصلات الخطوط المواصلات تعمل عدد من
المحال التجاريه بشكل لافت كبير اصبحت
تقدم خدماتها
مخابز الان تقدم خدماتها لكثير من
المواطنين على مستوى الامداد الكهربائي
والمائي متوفر وليست فيه يعني ربما قطوعات
عدد من المستشفيات الكبيره في المنطقه
التي كانت قد توقفت الان اصبحت تقدم جزء
من الخدمات المهمه في هذه اللحظات يعني
خصوصا للمستشفيات المركزيه التي كانت
معينه منطقه الاذاعه والتلفزيون عدد من
مناطق المهندسين كانت تنفتح فيها وتنتشر
فيها اقوات الدعم السريع وهذا ما يجعل
يعني الكثيرين مثلا يتفاعلون بين المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها قوات الشعب المسلحه
والمناطق التي تسيطر عليها الدعم السريع
في تردد خدمات او في عدم الوصول
والاستجابه لتلك المناطق شكرا عمار ابو
شيبه الصحفي كنت معي من ام درمان الان
ينضم الينا سالم الهاشمي العربيه من
الخرطوم ايضا سالم اهلا بك معنا كنا نتحدث
الان مع ضيفنا عمار عن الوضع تقريبا في ام
درمان انت اليوم تنقلت في ارجاء الخرطوم
نامل ان تعطينا صوره واضحه كيف هي الاجواء
اليوم في اول يوم من هذه الهدنه الخامسه
نعم اهلا بكم بكل الساده المشاهدين ما
زلنا ننقل هذه الاحداث من داخل الخرطوم
هنا العديد من المظاهر الان في هذه
اللحظات وهي مظاهر عسكريه وكل تاكيد الان
في هذه اللحظات نستمع الى اصوات مختلفه
لاصوات مدافع ثقيله وقبل قليل استمعنا الى
دوي لهذه المدافع بصوره كبيره جدا
احدث ضجه هنا في الخرطوم
وهناك ايضا تحليق للطائرات ربما هو
استهداف وكذلك استهداف من الجيش السوداني
للمناطق التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريعون في الخرطوم وكذلك رد قوات الدعم
السريع بمضادات للطائرات كان صوتها عالي
جدا في هذه المناطق يسمع بوضوح في هذه
المنطقه تحديدا يمكن من خلال الكاميرا ان
نرى هذه المناطق التي
تلتهب منها وتخرج منها السنه الدخان في
مناطق متفرقه لعل جزءا منها قد يكون في
الخرطوم والجزء الاخر في مدينه بحري كذلك
في مناطق متفرقه من بحري واندرمان كذلك
وهو تجدد للاشتباكات انا اعلم بالدقه
والمضادات ايضا من قبل الدعم السريع ام خف
الان
الان خفت بالفعل لكنها كانت بدويه ثقيل
جدا قبل عشر دقائق من الان في هذه المناطق
التي نرى منها السنه الدخان هنا من
الخرطوم هذه المناطق هي في الجانب الذي
عليه الان الكاميرا هو الجانب جزء من
مدينه بحري وام درمان كذلك
والجانب من هنا ايضا في المنطقه الاخرى في
مدينه بحري هذه السنه الدخان ربما هو ايضا
استهداف لقوات الدعم السريع عن المناطق
التي تتمركز بها رد كذلك من قوات الدعم
السريع بالمضادات للطائرات مدافع ثقيل
استمعنا اليها بقوه في هذه اللحظات او قبل
دقائق الان ما زالت
تعمل هذه او تضج هذه الاصوات هنا في
الخرطوم طب سالم
بن صرت هل يمكن القول بانه اعاده الحياه
الى طبيعتها من الصعب قول ذلك
بالضبط من الصعب قول ذلك في هذه اللحظات
لانه ما زالت هذه الاصوات بدويها في كل
ارجاء ولايه الخرطوم مما يجعل مساله عوده
الحياه الى طبيعتها
فيه صعوبه في هذا الوقت خاصه واننا الان
نتابع هذا الدوي ما زال مستمرا حتى
الشوارع تبدو شبه خاليه من الماره كذلك
عدا جزء قليل من المواطنين الذين خرجوا
لقضاء احتياجاتهم يضاف الى ذلك ان بعض
المواطنين كذلك خرجوا من اجل عمليات
النزوح التي رسلنا جزءا منها اليوم في
الخروج الى ولايات مجاوره
من الخرطوم الى مناطق اكثر امنا
تحدثنا مع العاملين في هذا المجال وهم
الذين هم الموجودون في هذه
في هذه المناطق التي ياتي اليها المواطنون
للخروج من ولايه الخرطوم في هذه
المحطات تحدثنا اليهم تحدثوا على انه
الاعداد في ازدياد وان حتى الاسعار غير
ثابته كذلك هناك تذبذب في اسعار
المواصلات نفسها في اسعار التذاكر وتختلف
من يوم لاخر ومن حافله لاخرى كل هذا يجعل
هذا عبئا ايضا على المواطن حتى اذا اراد
ان يخرج من هذه المنطقه الملتهبه يجد
صعوبه في ذلك تواجهه صعوبات اخرى منها على
سبيل المثال مثلا اسعار المواصلات نفسها
الوصول الى هذه المحطه كذلك شكى مواطنون
من صعوبه وصولهم الى هنا خاصه وان الطرق
يعني تنتشر فيها قوات والمظاهر العسكريه
ظاهره ومعهم اطفال وهناك خوف وقلق وتوتر
في المرور بهذه الطرق حتى يصلوا الى
اذا اردت ان اعود الى الصوره التي امامنا
على شاشه العربيه وهي السنه الدخان هل
يمكن ان تشرح لنا جغرافيه هذه المنطقه هل
هي مثلا يعني يقتلها مدنيون هل هي مقرات
عسكريه ام من الصعب عليكم تعلموا بالضبط
من اين تاتي هذه
هذا الدخان من اين ياتي
نعم هذه المنطقه هي الان في اقصى شمال
الخرطوم مما يلي مدينه بحري وربما تكون في
مدينه بحري هي الجزء الاقصى من الجنوب
جنوب مدينه بحري هذه المنطقه هي فيها
العديد من المناطق بالتحديد لا اعلم هل هي
يعني منطقه سكنيه او لا من الصعوبه ان
نتكهن بذلك الان لكن يمكن القول انها
منطقه او مدينه بحري وربما ان تكون كذلك
مدينه ام درمان ايضا
يعني بالحديث عن
ربما تكون مدينه ام درمان قاعه الصداقه او
بالقرب منها او قصر الصداقه بالقرب من هذه
المنطقه وهي منطقه عسكريه هذه المنطقه
وربما تكون امدرمان وربما تكون بحري لا
ادري بدقه لانه الصوره غير واضحه من الان
المكان بعيد جدا لكنه بالتحديد هو اقصى
شمال غربي الخرطوم وهي اما غرب بحري او
شرق اندرمان سالم اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
الوضع الانساني وخاصه المستشفيات يعني منذ
اليوم الاول لهذا
الصرح اكثر من دفع الثمن هو القطاع الطبي
والصحي وضع المستشفيات الان هل عاد بعضها
الى العمل اما زالت خارج الخدمه ما هو وضع
الطاقم والكادر الطبي
المستلزمات الطبيه الادويه هل يستطيعون
الحصول عليها
ما زال الكوادر الطبيه
وكل من له اهتمام بهذا الموضوع موضوع
الصحي في السودان يعانون من العديد من
المصاعب ويجتهدون في تذليل هذه العقبات
ويطالبون كذلك بان يلتزم الطرفين النزاع
بالهدنه وفتح المعابر والممرات كذلك لوصول
الكوادر الطبيه للمستشفيات يضاف اليها
ايضا اهميه ان يكونوا قادرين على ان تصلهم
المساعدات اللوجستيه فيما يتعلق بالطوارئ
وكل ما يتعلق باحتياجات المستشفيات كل هذه
الامور تجعل
تجعل الكوادر الطبيه تبحث دائما عن الافضل
في هذا الامر لكن على ارض الواقع هناك
معاناه كبيره جدا يعاني تعانيها يعانيها
هذا القطاع الان نستمع الى هذا الدوي ربما
يكون
واضحا دليل انفجار في ذات المنطقه التي
نراها على الشاشه الان
لم اسمعك
بوضوح سالم
نعم الان نستمع الى دليل انفجار في هذاك
المنطقه التي عليها الكاميرا الان
دليل انفجار اخر تتكرر هذه ايضا بالعوده
الى الموضوع الصحي يتحدث كل الكوادر
الطبيه تتحدث عن معاناه حقيقيه تعانيها
هذه المستشفيات وبحث عن
يعني طريقه افضل لاداره الازمه الصحيه
التي يمر بها السودان خاصه بعد المناشدات
التي ناشدتها ناشدتها القطاعات المهنيه
المتعلقه بالصحه في السودان ناشدت اكثر من
مره فيما يتعلق بالوضع الصحي في اغلاق عدد
من المستشفيات كذلك في مهاجمه المستشفيات
وقصف هذه المستشفيات يضاف الى ذلك ان هناك
جهات ايضا تحدثت عن ان هناك جهات تحتل هذه
المستشفيات جهاد عسكريه ايضا دخلت الى هذه
المستشفيات كل هذه الامور تجعل من القطاع
الصحي الذي كان هشا اكثر هشاشه وربما عدم
قدره هذا القطاع على تقديم الخدمه اللازمه
للمرضى والمصابين بالنسبه
هل يمكن القول بانها اعاده بشكل جيد ام
مازالت هناك ازمه بهذا الاطار
نعم ما زالت مشكله المياه بالذات في مدينه
بحري واحياء من مدينه الخرطوم ام درمان ما
زالت لم تروح مكانها حتى الان هناك اشكال
في الامداد المائي يتعلق بالمحطات محطات
المياه والاعطال التي صاحبتها وعدم قدره
الحكومه للوصول الى هذه المحطات لصيانتها
يضاف الى ذلك ايضا مساله الكهرباء التي
ايضا هي متذبذبه في العديد من المناطق
توجد احياء كامله ما زالت بدون كهرباء منذ
اندلاع هذه الازمه وحتى هذه اللحظه هذه
الامور كلها كانت قد وعدت ولايه الخرطوم
بالسعي لعلاج مشكله المياه ومشكله
الكهرباء وقد بدات بالفعل وهناك احياء
عادت اليها الكهرباء لكنها متذبذبه هناك
احياء عادت اليها المياه كذلك لكن ما زالت
هنالك احياء كبيره جدا تعاني من نقص
المياه والاكثر بحسب رصدنا حتى الان هي
مدينه بحري ربما هي الاكثر تضررا في موضوع
المياه والجزء الجنوبي الغربي من مدينه ام
درمان كذلك
متضرر من المياه والكهرباء ايضا نعم شكرا
لك سالم الهاشم وراس العربي دائما سنكون
معك في النشاط اللاحقه لتطلعنا على كل
المستجدات والتطورات
الى هنا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه هذه
الساعه ولكن دائما التغطيه مستمره على
العربيه والان ننتقل الى الزميل ابراهيم
بدر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات